This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. It's New York City, 1882. At night, the city is mostly dark, but it won't be for long. Thomas Edison has already invented the phonograph, the automatic telegraph, and the first commercially viable light bulb. He really could have stopped right there, but he was still young, only 35 years old. And then he had the brilliant idea of doing something even more ambitious. He wanted to construct, to design, the electrical system that would supply electricity for those bulbs. That's Philip Shoei, he wrote The Grid. It's a history of how society uses and loses electricity. The Edison illuminating company built a power station in Lower Manhattan, right in the shadow
这里是99%隐形。我是罗马·马尔斯。那是1882年的纽约市。夜晚，这座城市大部分时间都是黑暗的，但这种情况不会持续太久。托马斯·爱迪生已经发明留声机、自动电报机以及第一个商业上可行的电灯泡。他本可以在那里停下来，但他还很年轻，只有35岁。然后他萌生了一个更具雄心的天才想法。他想建造、设计能够为这些灯泡供电的电力系统。那是菲利普·索伊，他写了《电网》。这是一部关于社会如何使用和失去电力的历史。爱迪生照明公司在下曼哈顿建立了一个发电站，就在刚刚建成的布鲁克林大桥的阴影下。
of the newly constructed Brooklyn Bridge. The first grid was small, about one square mile, and it worked so well that soon all across the country, these little self-contained electrical systems started popping up. In the coming 10 and 20, 30 years, the grid got larger and larger. As the grid grew, it made modern life possible.
在新修建的布鲁克林大桥旁边。第一个电网很小，大约有一平方英里，它的运行效果如此之好，以至于不久之后，全国各地都开始涌现出这些小型的自给自足的电力系统。在接下来的10年、20年、30年里，电网变得越来越大。随着电网的发展，它使现代生活成为可能。
It powered electric lights, running water, sewage pumps, elevators, and air conditioning. But the bigger the grid got, the more complicated it got, and the more the possibility of failure crept in. Whenever we talk about large, designed, human-made, complicated, electrified things. It sometimes takes four or five things together going wrong, but if the system is complicated enough, then the chances of something bad happening go up. Which brings us to New York City's blackout of 1977.
它为电灯、自来水、排污泵、电梯和空调提供动力。但电网越大，它就越复杂，发生故障的可能性也就越大。每当我们谈论大型的、设计的、人造的、复杂的、通电的事物时。有时需要四五件事同时出错，但如果系统足够复杂，那么发生坏事的几率就会上升。这就把我们带到了1977年的纽约市大停电。
It wasn't the first blackout or even the biggest, but it might have been the most infamous. That's producer Delaney Hall. And oh yeah, this story, it's not about Thomas Edison. Though it begins with the electrical grid, he started building back in 1882. A grid that got so big, it's been called the most massive engineering project of the 20th century. This story is about what happens when you disconnect people from that grid for one hot night in New York City. It was just time.
这不是第一次大停电，甚至不是最大的一次，但它可能是最臭名昭著的。那是制作人德兰尼·霍尔。哦，对了，这个故事不是关于托马斯·爱迪生的。虽然它始于他在1882年开始建造的电网。一个变得如此巨大的电网，被称为20世纪最宏大的工程项目。这个故事讲的是，在一个炎热的纽约之夜，当你把人们从那个电网中断开时会发生什么。时候到了。
What we're gonna do right here is go back. It was time for a new... Way back. Interpretation. Back into time. That's hip-hop pioneer grandmaster cats. And he says on that night, when the lights went out, a movement was born. He says on that night when the lights went out, a movement was born. If I was a kid in the 50s, I'd have been Chuck Berry.
我们要在这里做的是倒回过去。是时候迎来一个新的……很久以前。解读。回到过去。那是嘻哈先驱大宗师卡兹。他说，就在那晚灯熄灭时，一个运动诞生了。他说，就在那晚灯熄灭时，一个运动诞生了。如果我是50年代的孩子，我就会成为查克·贝里。
You know what I'm saying? If I was in the 30s or 40s, I'd have been a jazz artist. It's the same energy that every generation, you know, exercises, and it just comes out in different forms. This is Grand Master Caz, and yes, I was there during the night of the 1977 New York City city blackout and survived. Thunderstorm swept over the New York City area on a hot night in July. What happened in 1977, first of all you have what this might even be the technical war for an act of God.
你知道我在说什么吗？如果我在30年代或40年代，我会成为一个爵士艺术家。这是每一代人都在运用的那种相同的能量，它只是以不同的形式表现出来。这是大宗师卡兹，是的，我在1977年纽约市大停电的那个晚上经历了并幸存了下来。雷暴在7月的一个炎热夜晚席卷了纽约市地区。1977年发生了什么，首先，你甚至可以说这是上帝的旨意。
A lightning bolt came down and struck a overhead transmission line. When lightning adds a bunch of extra electricity to a transmission line, the line shuts itself off at the circuit breaker. When one line shuts off, the electricity starts squeezing into smaller and smaller channels, like how cars on the freeway crowd into a single lane when the other lanes are blocked. This is all fairly normal so far, but then... Just 10 or 15 minutes later, another flash of lightning. And this knocked out a couple of lines. So now you've got even more electricity with
一道闪电劈下来，击中了一根架空输电线路。当闪电给输电线路增加一堆额外的电力时，线路就会在断路器处自动切断。当一条线路切断时，电力开始挤进越来越小的通道，就像高速公路上的车辆在其他车道被封锁时挤进单条车道一样。到目前为止，这一切都相当正常，但随后……就在10或15分钟后，又一道闪电。这击毁了几条线路。所以现在你有更多的电力，却有
fewer lines to distribute it. And it was hot outside, really hot, which meant that lots of New Yorkers were running lots of air conditioners putting an extra burden on the system. And now they started to have trouble. There wasn't enough room for all the electricity to flow. And so Khan Edison, that same power company that Thomas Edison started way back when he was laying the lines for the first electrical grid, started doing that the very last thing they like to do, which is to turn off whole neighborhoods.
更少的线路来分配它。而且外面很热，非常热，这意味着许多纽约人都在开着许多空调，给系统带来了额外的负担。现在他们开始遇到麻烦了。没有足够的空间让所有的电力流动。于是康爱迪生，也就是托马斯·爱迪生早在为第一个电网铺设线路时创立的同一家电力公司，开始做他们最不喜欢做的事情，那就是关闭整个街区。
One by one. By one. Okay, so the year the blackout, hip hop was starting to spread, but it was still pretty much a Bronx kind of thing. It didn't have a name, you know, people refer to it. Oh, y'all still doing that hippity-hoppity stuff. Hip-hop, hippity-hopp, hip-to-the-hop, hip-hop, the hippity-hipp-hop. Okay, hip-hop, you know what I mean? I do remember what New York was like in that era, and I remember how chaotic it was. That's Joe Schloss. I'm a professor at City University of New York, and I research and practice hip-hop culture. New York City had experienced a major blackout in 1965 in which the city had stayed mostly
一个接一个。一个接一个。好吧，在大停电那一年，嘻哈音乐开始传播，但它基本上还是布朗克斯的一种东西。它没有名字，你知道，人们提起它。哦，你们还在搞那种嘻哈玩意儿。嘻哈，嘻哈，嘻哈，嘻哈，嘻哈。好吧，嘻哈，你知道我的意思吗？我确实记得那个时代的纽约是什么样的，我记得它是多么混乱。那是乔·施洛斯。我是纽约城市大学的教授，我研究和实践嘻哈文化。纽约市经历过1965年的大停电，当时这座城市大部分时间都保持着
calm. During the blackout of 1965, residents treated the situation with good humor and camaraderie. But things felt different in 1977. It was like a powder gig, like something like that was on the verge of happening all the time, all it took was something to push it over the edge. A couple years before, in 1975, New York City was in such a dire financial situation that it had turned the federal government for a bailout. President Gerald Ford's response was a resounding no prompting the New York Daily News to run
平静。在1965年的停电期间，居民们以幽默和友情对待这种情况。但在1977年，情况感觉不同了。这就像一个火药桶，就像某种事情随时都可能发生边缘一样，所需要的只是有什么东西把它推过边缘。几年前的1975年，纽约市陷入了如此严重的财务困境，以至于它向联邦政府寻求救助。杰拉尔德·福特总统的回应是斩钉截铁的“不”，促使《纽约每日新闻》刊登了
a now famous headline. Ford to City, dropped dead. In 1977, things were still bad for New York, and in the Bronx, they were even worse. You had neighborhoods that had lost something like 46% of the population. My name is Lloyd Altan, and I am the Bronx Barrow Historian. And there were blocks, I have the block, I have the block of rubble. And beyond that, what was on the horizon were buildings that were empty and boarded up.
一个现在著名的头条新闻。福特对城市说：去死吧。1977年，纽约的情况仍然很糟，而在布朗克斯，情况甚至更糟。有些社区失去了大约46%的人口。我叫劳埃德·阿尔坦，我是布朗克斯区历史学家。那里有街区，我有这个街区，我有废墟的街区。除此之外，地平线上看到的是空置并用木板封起来的建筑。
Really, it looked like Berlin right after the bombings in World War II. The municipal government had forgotten about the Bronx. And then the youth in the Bronx had been forgotten about by the older people in the Bronx. We didn't have those music programs, all those will cut out. When we were kids, you know, we had them,
真的，它看起来就像二战轰炸后的柏林。市政府已经忘记了布朗克斯。布朗克斯的年轻人也被布朗克斯的老年人遗忘了。我们没有那些音乐节目，所有这些都被砍掉了。当我们还是孩子的时候，你知道，我们拥有它们，
but those intermediate years, it's like, we didn't have none of that anymore. So they were like a forgotten minority of a forgotten minority of a forgotten minority. So, I mean, you can really see how people could feel that they had been left behind. I mean, it's hard to describe, you know what I mean? Cause now that we older, I can look back and say, wow, we got through some pretty rough
但在中间的那些年里，就像我们再也没有这些东西了一样。所以他们就像是一个被遗忘的少数群体的被遗忘的少数群体的被遗忘的少数群体。所以，我的意思是，你真的可以看出人们怎么会觉得他们被抛弃了。我的意思是，这很难描述，你知道我的意思吗？因为现在我们长大了，我可以回过头来说，哇，我们经历了一些相当艰难的
times, you know, but rough, if you were born into rough times, then it's just times. That's what it goes for. And once again my friend, the fuck your beat has no end. We about to take it on down to the 8M for you and your friend. Because the sound you hear is kind of tough on your ear, coming at you so loud and clear, so you have no fear. On the evening of July 13th, 1977, the same day as the blackout, Grandmaster Kaz and his partner, Disco Wiz, had been challenged to a DJ battle by another group of DJs. So we decided to take our equipment out into the park. We used to hang out, play basketball, and then every day so that's where the
时期，你知道，但是艰难，如果你出生在艰难的时期，那么它就只是时期。事情就是这样。我的朋友，你的节奏没有尽头。我们要为你和你的朋友把节奏带到8M。因为你听到的声音对你的耳朵来说有点刺耳，传过来那么响亮清晰，所以你不用害怕。1977年7月13日傍晚，也就是停电同一天，大宗师卡兹和他的搭档迪斯科·维兹受到另一群DJ的DJ对决挑战。所以我们决定把我们的设备带到公园里。我们经常去那里闲逛，打篮球，然后每天都在那里，所以
battle was going to take place. They set up all their stuff, so I had my side. I just remember them having a very, very good professional sound system, and us having our thrown together, you know, in pieces, said. The two groups of DJs started to battle. I was doing this little combo that I used to do, and one song was a song by DC Lurou And I was cut it up with this other breakbeat Then then then then then ah Love love love and I was killing them
对决就要在那里举行。他们摆好了所有的东西，所以我有我这一边。我只记得他们有一个非常非常好的专业音响系统，而我们的则是东拼西凑的，你知道，七零八落的。两组DJ开始对决。我正在做这个我经常用的小组合，其中一首歌是DC·勒鲁的歌，我用另一个断奏把它切碎了，然后，然后，爱，爱，爱，我把他们秒杀了
Now remember that the hype of everybody, you know, being really excited. And then the record just started slowing down, you know what I mean? Just, you know, you know how it turned to be cut off and then it just, ooooooooh, that kind of situation. So quite naturally, we thought it was us. We thought we had drained too much power and we shorted out, you know, the electricity. So, we're frantic. We're looking around. We're checking buttons. We're checking switches. We're seeing what's up. Cause this is death in the battle. If your system cons out on you. But after a while, everything around us started getting dark.
现在回想起来，每个人都很狂热，你知道，真的很兴奋。然后唱片开始慢下来，你知道我的意思吗？就是，你知道，你知道它是怎么被切断的，然后它就，呜————，那种情况。所以很自然地，我们以为是我们。我们以为我们消耗了太多的电力，把电短路了，你知道。所以，我们很狂乱。我们四处张望。我们检查按钮。我们检查开关。我们看看是怎么回事。因为这在对决中是致命的。如果你的系统在关键时刻掉链子。但过了一会儿，我们周围的一切都开始变暗。
I mean, windows, the apartment buildings around us were all dark. It kind of came over everybody at the same time, like, oh, blackout! Generators all over the city had been turning themselves off one by one. And then the biggest generator in the city. A machine called Big Alice. It turned itself off and with that just about everything left that was still lit up in New York turned off. All five burrows of New York City went dark. But if you turn all those fluorescent lights off that glow that diffuse light goes away and you can look up, pow, there it is, the Milky Way.
我的意思是，窗户，我们周围的公寓楼都是黑的。它几乎同时向每个人袭来，哦，停电了！全市的发电机一个接一个地关闭。然后是全市最大的发电机。一台被称为“大爱丽丝”的机器。它自己关闭了，随着它的关闭，纽约几乎所有还亮着的东西都熄灭了。纽约市所有的五个区都陷入黑暗。但是如果你把所有那些荧光灯都关掉，那种发光、漫射的光就会消失，你可以抬头看，砰，那就是银河系。
goes away and you can look up, POW, there it is, the Milky Way. If people took a minute to gaze up at the newly visible night sky, they didn't stargaze for long. Because pretty soon, things started to feel tense. The stores started to close. Like the local bodegas on each corner, we would hear the gate slamming down. Shroom. Shroom is like they knew what was happening. They knew what was going on. They like, we closing up now.
消失了，你可以抬头看，砰，那就是银河系。如果人们花了一分钟抬头凝视新露出的夜空，他们也没有观星太久。因为很快，事情开始变得紧张起来。商店开始关门。就像每个街角的本地杂货店，我们会听到铁门砰地关上的声音。轰。轰就像他们知道发生了什么。他们知道是怎么回事。他们好像在说，我们现在要关门了。
New Yorkers reactions were varied. Some through parties, some went walking, and many seemed bemused. Some stayed up in the bars and clubs, and some went out to help. But many took advantage of the sudden chaos. The park was right around the corner from the grand concourse in the Bronx, which is like shopping area all the way up and down. Stores, electronic stores, toy stores, furniture stores, pet stores, I mean everything. Here in the corner of 130 just streets was Broadway.
纽约人的反应各不相同。有些人办派对，有些人去散步，许多人显得茫然。有些人呆在酒吧和俱乐部里，有些人则出去帮忙。但许多人利用了突然的混乱。公园就在布朗克斯宏伟干道的转角附近，那里到处都是购物区。商店、电子产品商店、玩具店、家具店、宠物店，应有尽有。在130街的拐角处就是百老汇。
I'm amazed to find the right people in my eyes are singers sewing machines, stores systematically being alluded by a crowd of about 40 or 50 people. I saw people taking stuff that people had stolen, you know what I mean? They couldn't get in this store, so they waited for people to come out to steal something and then just grab it from them. It was chaos that night. And it was exciting afterwards. But while it was going on, it was scary. In the Bronx, looters smashed a steel door of an auto showroom and drove off with 15 new cars, valued at $250,000.
我很惊讶地发现在我的眼里合适的人是歌手、缝纫机，商店正被大约40到50人的群体系统地洗劫。我看到人们拿走别人偷的东西，你知道我的意思吗？他们进不去这家商店，所以他们等着人们出来偷东西，然后直接从他们手里抢。那天晚上是一片混乱。事后令人兴奋。但在进行的过程中，它是可怕的。在布朗克斯，掠夺者砸碎了一个汽车展厅的钢门，开走了15辆价值25万美元的新车。
Every other block has a high five store, a liquor store, a sporting goods store that was broken into. Looting was rampant, and people stole all kinds of stuff, including DJ equipment, turntables. They wanted to become DJs. They wanted to, you know what I mean? And equipment cost. And so that's why you can count the amount of DJs that they work. I even, like I said, I even got a new mixer. I went right to the place where I bought my first set of DJ equipment.
每隔一个街区就有一家五金店、一家酒类专卖店、一家被砸开的体育用品商店。抢劫猖獗，人们偷了各种各样的东西，包括DJ设备、唱盘。他们想成为DJ。他们想，你知道我的意思吗？而且设备很贵。这就是为什么你能数清他们工作的DJ数量。我甚至，就像我说的，我甚至买了一个新混音器。我直接去了我买第一套DJ设备的地方
I spent money in here and I went by and I got me a mixer out of there. The blackout lasted 24 hours and some people, including Grandmaster Kaz, think it catalyzed the growing hip-hop movement. After the blackout, all this new wealth that I like to call it, you know what I mean, was founded by people and they just, you know, opportunity sprang from that. And you can see the differences before the blackout and after. So the question is, did they go and seal turntables and things like that so that they could actually become those disshokies?
我在那里花了钱，我顺路去拿回了一个混音器。停电持续了24个小时，一些人，包括大宗师卡兹，认为它催化了不断发展的嘻哈运动。停电后，所有这些我喜欢称之为新财富的东西，你知道我的意思吗？是由人们建立的，他们只是，你知道，机遇从那里萌芽。你可以看到停电前后的区别。所以问题是，他们去抢唱盘之类的东西，是为了真正成为那些DJ吗？
I think it's true. I cannot rule out the possibility. But I think it's also important to keep in mind that basically hip hop history is an oral history at this point. But I cannot say definitively that that actually did happen. And that it's all mythology in some sense, the true stories as well as the false stories. We have to keep our music alive. We have to keep exercising this need, this inner need, from our soul to experience music. Let's go, like this.
我认为这是真的。我不能排除这种可能性。但我认为同样重要的是要记住，基本上嘻哈历史在这一点上是口述历史。但我不能明确地说这真的发生了。在某种程度上，这全都是神话，真实的故事以及虚假的故事。我们必须让我们的音乐活着。我们必须继续锻炼这种需求，这种来自灵魂的内在需求，去体验音乐。我们走吧，就这样。
Go down and we're smiling at the bottom at the top of the dam, young baby. Say I was a rival to the show, a child, more a child. As a whisper, go ride the bottom to the bottom Say I was a shy one, but sure, I'm shy and more shy As soon as we're gonna rock the side and do the part of people If everything you listen to I'm gonna get paid And as they say, they eat your soul I know you're okay, the zero's rock the microphone When other race, style, customer, free, yes, Cindy
下到底部，我们在大坝顶部微笑，年轻的宝贝。说我是节目的竞争对手，一个孩子，更像一个孩子。像一阵低语，去骑到底部，到底部。说我是个害羞的人，但当然，我很害羞，更加害羞。一旦我们要震撼这一边并参与人们的部分。如果你听到的所有东西我都会得到报酬。正如他们所说，他们吃你的灵魂。我知道你没事，零点震撼麦克风。当其他种族，风格，顾客，自由，是的，辛迪
We gotta be easy, we'll tell you everyone's desire To be young, baby, Cindy 99% Invisible was produced this week by Delaney Hall and Katie Mangle with Sam Greenspan Avery Truffle, and me Roman Mars. This episode was based off of a piece that Delaney did for the In the Dark Radio series based in London. We are a project of 91.7 local public radio KALW in San Francisco and produced by the offices of Arxine in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. You can find this show and like the show on Facebook. All of us are on Twitter, in California. Radio Tapio. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们得轻松点，我们会告诉你每个人的愿望。做个年轻的宝贝，辛迪。本周的《99%隐形》由德兰尼·霍尔和凯蒂·曼格尔制作，萨姆·格林斯潘、艾弗里·特鲁夫以及我罗马·马尔斯协助。本期节目改编自德兰尼为总部设在伦敦的《黑暗之中》广播系列制作的一篇报道。我们是旧金山91.7地方公共广播电台KALW的项目，由加利福尼亚州美丽市中心奥克兰的阿克辛办公室制作。你可以在Facebook上找到并点赞这个节目。我们所有人在加利福尼亚州都有Twitter。电台塔皮奥。本期节目尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。